Once described as “no different
to the vomit of a drunkard”,
sushi has been on quite a journey.
The story of sushi goes back
to prehistoric southeast Asia.
There, fish was preserved by
packing it with salt and cooked rice,
resulting in a vinegary,
fermented fish, and a gloopy rice –
the rice part was truly disgusting
and usually discarded.
In Japan, where
the technique remained in use
as it died out elsewhere,
it was called nare-sushi
- nare meaning aged.
This was the definition of sushi
for several centuries.
But by the 15th Century,
especially in coastal areas
where fish was more
plentiful all year round,
people were leaving it for less time
- and daring to eat the rice,
which, eaten early,
was pleasantly tangy.
Two hundred years later,
with Japanese demand
for the taste of sushi booming,
an even quicker version was invented,
which involved simply adding vinegar
to the rice to flavour it.
Finally in the 1820s,
in what is now Tokyo,
raw fish - as fresh as possible
- was added to the rice,
now no longer aged at all,
and modern sushi was born.
The Japanese called it haya-sushi
- haya meaning fast.
Japan was a very closed
country until 1854,
so it wasn’t until the late
Victorian period that Westerners,
particularly Americans,
started spending time in Japan
and encountered sushi.
It required
an incredible level of skill.
Getting it wrong wasn’t just
annoying, but potentially risky
- one rare delicacy, pufferfish,
which today is tightly regulated,
is highly poisonous
if badly prepared.
It wasn’t until
the 1970s that sushi,
both as a luxury treat and
as a cheap street food,
started to be seen outside Japan.
It first emerged in California, which
had a large Japanese population,
and followed the Japanese
across the world.
Californians, initially aghast
at the idea of eating raw fish,
grew to love it.
But, to encourage them,
Japanese sushi chefs
came up with the Californian Roll,
which originally contained
cooked crab.
Other Westernised recipes followed,
including the decidedly 1980s
Philadelphia Roll,
with smoked salmon and cream cheese.
Most Western countries don’t allow
fresh raw fish to be used
because of the danger
from parasites –
fish must be frozen, which
kills the parasites, before use.
As sushi spread, the deeply ingrained
Western fear of raw fish
meant that more and more
versions came into use
which relied on ingredients such as
cooked prawns, smoked fish or egg,
and where the often complex
side sauces were replaced
with simple soy sauce,
ginger and wasabi.
The ultimate Westernisation
is probably the Asian-Latin fusion
which is the sushi burrito,
invented in 2011.
The first sushi restaurant in the UK
opened in London in 1994,
in the City –
the heart of businessland.
Today, sushi is booming,
marketed as being healthy, convenient
and still just a little bit exotic.
The conveyer belt concept
used in many restaurants
adds a certain level of novelty,
as do the chopsticks
- although according
to many Japanese,
sushi is best eaten with the fingers.
Today, there are many types of sushi.
At its best it is often still very
expensive and very beautiful,
and its devotees can
be positively fanatical.
A Japanese apprenticeship lasts at
least five years for a sushi chef,
and both Japan and the UK
have sushi restaurants
which have been awarded
three Michelin stars.
Not bad for a food which started
as a way to stop fish from rotting.